c'est l'édito d'alexis paul un
[Musique]
bon soir alexis alors pour un président
qui compte 112 ans on va pas être voilà
à faire des plans sur la comète m'enfin
on va imaginer qui qui qui va un petit
peu envie de briguer un second mandat
emmanuel macron faut dire que cette
séquence internationale est un petit peu
du du pain bénit n'est ce pas abbas est
sur qu là pour emmanuel macron ça lui
permet d'user de sa stature
présidentielle jusqu'au bout d'éviter
d'enjamber la campagne électorale et
emmanuel macron c'est quand même le roi
de la fuite en avant le roi de leskiw à
la fois il ne défend pas son bilan il se
projette dans l'avenir il se pose aussi
en pacificateur celui qui va apporter la
solution en ukraine comme si c'était que
lui ce serait merveilleux et qui va
peut-être même vaincre le coc vide avec
ces mesures formidable comme le pass
vaccinale donc il est en train d'écrire
une séquence de communication pour
lancer sa campagne sur les bases de
macron le sauveur on avait on a tous eu
avec emmanuel macron depuis cinq ans il
nous manquait le sauveur le voilà qui
arrive à sortir de son avion retour de
berlin pour aller en plus récupérer les
turbines à general electric alors qu'il
avait oeuvré bien sûr pour vendre ses
turbines à la lente reprise américaine
donc c'est vraiment de la communication
du marketing politique encore et
toujours et un moyen pour emmanuel
macron d'éviter le débat d'éviter
d'entrer en campagne
jimenez macro le sauveur c'est parfois
ce qu'on pouvait presque lire dans les
médias français après sa rencontre hier
avec vladimir poutine de la part des
journalistes dont certains avaient la
chance d'ailleurs de l'avoir accompagné
dans l'avion présidentiel c'est
d'ailleurs la tradition le
fonctionnement des voyages de presse on
est dans l'avion avec le président et
ont fait la tournée avec lui on a droit
à une petite phrase en off qui sont
ensuite reprises dans la presse
absolument alors il ya deux façons de
faire soyez un avion pour la presse sur
les long courriers sous harnais dans
l'avion présidentiel
effectivement on peut poser des
questions le président vient vous voir
sortez de ces quartiers présidentielle
pour rabab donner les bonnes petites
phrases pour montrer qu'il est proche
des médias qu'il est aussi aux commandes
de tout et c'est vraiment hagiographique
on est là quasiment dans de la
propagande d'état évidemment on va avoir
droit aux reportages emmanuel macron
offrons la campagne de l'est d'emmanuel
macron la campagne de russie à fournir à
tous à peu près sur ce passage en
ukraine et en russie des modèles macron
c'est vrai que la presse présidentielle
c'est une institution c'est aussi une
façon bien de d'assurer que la parole
présidentielle et reprise telle quelle
que aussi lors des conférences de presse
certaines questions sont posées comme
sur le mali où d'autres pour s'assurer
que on peut faire passer des messages à
l'autre qui nous reçoit lors des voyages
présidentiels c'est clairement depuis
quelques jours quand je dis macro le
sauveur moi je le dis évidemment avec
ironie mais pour beaucoup de confrères
non ils le disent vraiment sincèrement
heureux de voir que le président
français est si formidable et allant
même jusqu à en rajouter c'est vrai
qu'on est bien traité lorsqu'on est la
presse présidentielle puisqu'on a droit
à quelques égards alors justement parmi
les petites questions verna forcément eu
sur la candidature dans cet avion
présidentiel
il va falloir et son gc ca
il s'est tant que emmanuel macron disent
qu'il est candidat parce que les pauvres
militants de la république en marche qui
commencera à faire campagne tous ceux
qui ont déjà offert leurs parrainages à
emmanuel macron seront ils orphelin
d'une non candidature
non évidemment c'est une question de
timing alors certains proches disent
entre le 10 et le 20 février bon alors
on y arrive mais il va falloir choisir
le bon timing bon timing c'est
évidemment à s'assurer que la vague ou
micron est derrière s'assurer aussi que
sur l'ukraine il n'y aura pas un
revirement de situation de joe biden on
l'a vu dans la crise des sous-marins les
américains peuvent tout à fait trahir et
mener le maquereau ou bien décider de
souris retardement et d'attaqués par
derrière donc il faut s'assurer pour lui
que son message et son sa promotion
puisqu'il est en promotion il n'est pas
encore en campagne peuvent fonctionner
et non pas retomber comme un soufflé si
jamais tout repartait dans le rouge et
si jamais il était
en échec sur ces deux thématiques donc
voilà c'est clairement maintenant le
temps pour emmanuel macron d'entrer dans
la campagne mais il va falloir qu'il
accepte de débattre avec tout le monde
et surtout de défendre un bilan
calamiteux aujourd'hui sortent les
chiffres de la balance du commerce
extérieur un déficit de 84 milliards
d'euros
je ne vois pas comment on peut défendre
un bilan de ce type là avec la dette qui
explose avec évidemment les dépenses
publiques aussi qu'ils sont dans le
rouge ça va être très compliqué même
s'il continue d'aller toujours dans la
fuite en avant de faire des chèques et
de dire que c'est le sauveur est le
meilleur président du monde reste à voir
merci avec six poulains